The condition for a cake is needed
35 grams of sugar and 50 grams of flour.
Let me stress it.
"For a cake 35 grams of sugar and 50 grams of flour are needed."
And then it is said:
"For a muffin, 30 grams of sugar is needed."
Let me also emphasize this.
A muffin is needed
30 grams of sugar and 65 grams of flour.
What do they want us to do?
Shona must use at least 460 grams of sugar.
Let me emphasize this with a different color.
"The Shona must use at least 460 grams of sugar,
to make cakes and muffins,
as she wants to use at most 970 grams of flour. "
I will use another color.
"And she wants to use
at most 970 grams of flour.
To create a system of inequalities,
which presents Shona's terms.
Let C denote the number of cakes she makes,
but the number of muffins he does. "
"Compile the inequality that it presents
the situation based on grams of sugar. "
And so - the situation based on grams of sugar.
That was highlighted here in green.
The Shona must use at least 460 grams of sugar,
to make cakes and muffins.
Let's see how we can record that.
How much sugar would she use for cakes?
Here we are told she needs it
35 grams of sugar for one cake.
So the amount of sugar it will use for all cakes,
will be 35 grams per cake ...
let me write it a bit clearer ...
35 grams per cake per cake count.
So that's how much sugar she's going to use for cakes.
How many grams of sugar will be used for muffins?
This will be 30 grams of sugar per muffin.
So we have plus 30 grams of muffin sugar
by the number of muffins.
So we have on M.
This is the total amount of sugar for cakes.
This is the total amount of sugar for muffins.
And if you bring them together,
this is the total amount of sugar it uses.
Subject to the condition
it should use at least 460 grams of sugar.
Everything here is in grams.
This should be greater or equal.
It should use at least 460 grams of sugar,
to do both.
So it is.
We can simply build inequality,
which presents the condition based on grams of sugar,
which is the condition here.
Now let's look at this next question:
"Compile the inequality that represents the condition
based on grams of flour. "
Well, that's what we highlighted here with orange.
It should use at most 970 grams of flour.
So we have no more than 970 grams.
How will we say this as an inequality?
How much flour will be used for cakes?
It uses 50 grams of flour for cake.
50 grams per cake per cake count.
This is the amount of flour it will use for cakes.
And then for the muffins:
it uses 65 grams of flour for muffin
by the number of muffins.
So this is the total amount of flour,
which she will use.
And this should be less than or equal to 970 grams.
Less than or equal to 970.
And we're ready.
And thus, if you want,
you can ask: "Which couples C and M
satisfy both inequalities? "
And then you can say, "Well, that's the combination
of the number of cakes and muffins she can make,
to satisfy its real conditions. "